[Music]
my name
is halo the new movie i watched ishonda
sheep armageddon it's very silly and
cute
me and will we're directors we helped
make the film for armageddon
and i would love to know what is the
movie about
our spaceship crashed on earth and the
man and the dog were like so scared
but it was just lula yeah
then she meant sean they did
everything together funny and crazy
stuff
where did they go um everywhere
halo i was going to ask you who's your
favorite character in the film
definitely lula he can do alien
cartwheels
and lula eats all the candy and drinks
all the soda
and goes crazy and then she went like
halo how much did you like the movie on
a scale of one to ten
a 100 wow
i'll upgrade it to 200.
the film has been nominated for an oscar
do you know what an oscar is
it's a statue and it's a award
i would give it a better prize like
they'll give you
200 puppies too 200 puppies where are we
gonna put all of those
what did you learn from the movie
friendship
did you feel happy or sad when lula got
home
i was actually happy outside because
he got home safely with her parents
she can always visit him again though
like every day
all right really good to meet you bye
bye